[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the most norm thing ever to not tell
everybody that you were dying
a total norm move too right yeah
sympathy
he got cancelled he could have put that
card on the table cancer [ __ ]
anyway
and he didn't even tell his best friends
he said he was going to kevin to take
care of his mom
tell me either he told out amiga he's
got a big race coming for him they
didn't tell adam
that's that's the last joke
genius comic though genius he was so uh
unique in his the way he expressed
himself how he was really thinking like
the way he would like he would say
something [ __ ] up to you in the green
room he would say the exact same thing
on stage it was just and he would say he
had this way of looking at things it was
absolutely unique to him yeah he bombed
a good bit too yeah
which must have been so fun to watch
caroline's once [ __ ] throwing down
one
my god it was like he still cares too
didn't care he got heckled he was
drinking a coca-cola and he got heckled
and he was like
i don't want to do this
i'm just going to go back to my act do
you know what i got to tell you this
what this canadian promoter told me they
go um i forget who it was but somebody
would
you probably know too that has
worked in comedy all these years
and they go you know coming up
when nor cause norms started in canada
you know he's canadian yeah
they go um
whenever he killed like killed in these
early years
working a weekend at yuck yucks or
something yeah
when the show was over he'd just hide or
just he'd just go in the green room and
sit there
but if he bombed which norm is the kind
of comic who like every other show yeah
because he literally like he just didn't
care he really he really didn't care he
really didn't do that people say that
and they're lying no he really genuinely
didn't doesn't care when we watch his
rose watch his talk show appearances he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
when he bombed which was like
semi-regularly
he would wait in the hallway to shake
audience members hands
so that they had to see him again
that
so they're leaving he's like how you
doing
hi
that is the most gangster yeah it
totally is but if he's like if i kill i
don't want to do that but anyway in the
morning norm's downstairs we'll have to
play in this poker tournament that's
part of the weekend deal the package
and norm's like man a lot of hot chicks
here hun i'm looking around it's like
nobody's
that nobody's hot in this area right
there hasn't been anybody hot here if
somebody here were hot you would know
about it immediately maybe on a calendar
they would be on the news yeah that
would be on the news yeah
yeah that would be on the news bro
yeah if a decent strand of jeans passed
through this town the [ __ ] fire
alarms would go off right there has not
been they would be up from the news to a
milk carton in like a week there has not
been a a unique strand of gtac to roll
through this area
in [ __ ]
since [ __ ] what norm was definitely
on pills if he was like looking around
here right ah there's some
tail here yeah so i thought he was
serious right because i don't really
know him i'm like yeah man there
definitely is and then he goes [ __ ] no
there is it just shook me
that's that's so him that's amazing
he like baited me into believing that he
yeah and then [ __ ] pulled the rug out
yeah
did he [ __ ] no there isn't really one of
the best comedy minds of all time i
remember colin quinn told me a story
once that you know one of my favorite
musicians ever leonard cohn being a
canadian would go see noah mcdonald play
whoa
and no one was like who's this guy who's
this old guy he didn't care that that
leonard cohen was norman donald wow
unbelievable yeah his gambling stories
on howard stern are incredible i read
his book i'm just i've seen everything
he's done this is dirty work is a great
comedy i love dirty work i met him i met
him once at the seller and i got a photo
with him and now i'm so glad i did he
did uh last comic standing he was the
only honest judge he would tell comics
they were hacks it was awesome my story
with norm is not it doesn't start out
great because i did uh last comic
standing in 2000 and whatever it never
aired
uh and i did my joke and i did well and
it was him it was damon damon wayans and
roseanne yeah and roseanne liked me
demon wayne's like
he was like
not
he was just like yeah he just like
smiled and left
i think he said right on i don't know
what he was just like barely there like
he wasn't
i don't remember anything either way
and then norm was like how many years
have you been doing comedy i'm like four
he's like what it takes 10 years to be a
comedian what are you doing here i was
like
and i remember that was the biggest gut
punch i got in stand up and i remember
being at the
hilton by uh where they shoot all those
shows but where is that universal city
yeah yeah yeah yeah i was in the hilton
and i was just like
like i couldn't even eat i was like this
is horrible and i spoke to that one of
the comics i was staying with at um
that point and he was like last comic
standing he's like you go in there and
they pay legends to tell you not to do
what you love
which is kind of fun but i got over it i
kept doing it and then he became a fan
of us later on and a lot of [ __ ] we were
doing and he was right you know i was a
four-year five-year comic then it's like
you do need more time to mature norm has
a joke he goes i got i got a new
neighbor i see the neighbor and i said
uh hey neighbor what do you do for a
living neighbor says uh norma
i'm a professor of logic down at the
university of science and norman says
what's that he goes well norm it's hard
for me to explain
it's easier to me just show you what i
do norm
do you have a doghouse and norm goes i
do and he goes well then you must have a
dog logically he goes i do have a dog
and he goes all right and if you have a
dog lodge the guy can assume you must
have a child you have a child norm and
he goes i do have a child because well
if you have a child logically i can
assume
you must be married to a woman are you
married to a woman in norman he goes i
am
his norm then logically i can assume
you're a straight white male and
normally wow that's amazing
so the next day norm's down on a bus
stop having a cigarette sees another one
of his neighbors neighbors because norms
you meet the new neighbor he goes yeah i
did
here's what's he do for a living because
he's a professor of logic down to the
university of science
he was what is that he goes well it's
hard for me to explain but it's much
easier for me to show
because then he goes yeah norm goes hey
do you have a dog house he goes no and
he goes well you must be a [ __ ]
why aren't we like we're all funny like
why can't we because that's a
problematic word and it's banned
but dude as far as like people to go
down a rabbit hole
for me it's him nor macdonald ric flair
uh
patrice
there's like three of them you could
just kind of go down
and it's just so different
and great and fresh and unique and i
thought there was a lot of similarity
in uh
as far as what they did patrice and norm
i thought there was a lot of similarity
it's it's brutal dude that guy was just
uh
just one of them he's such a nice guy
too he's such a nice guy and just i
thought just so mentally beyond
yeah all of us it was like he had this
rare mix of how
of the things he said were funny
and then also the way he said it was
funny but also the moments in between
when he was saying words
he made funny somehow and it was like
the pinnacle of of of of a stand-up
comedian it was like it was it was the
words the way you say it and then
sometimes you found yourself watching
nor macdonald
laughing
at the pauses
because of how absurd what he just said
was or
how or you couldn't wait what he was
going to say next or
just why did he pause
this way now
he just was a true comic
and he was one of those guys that just
had to be a comic you know and thank god
he chose to do stand-up because he was
great i think he was one of the best to
ever do it and you know the other day we
lost
a legend
you're kidding me no
we just found out that nor macdonald
passed away
oh my god i love norm mcdonald
he's young and there it goes
i don't know what to say me either
that was uh
breaking news but you'll know now when
you listen to this when uh when we
recorded it oh i'm just uh heartbroken
i love norm norm is from my home country
canada and from my home club yuck yucks
and i've worked with him many times do
you know norm yeah we worked together on
uh last comic standing i took the job
because i wanted to work with norm
mcdonald and we fought every day you
fought with him we not not like
getting but we we would joke back and
forth with each other
and it just it took a little while for
us to gel you know that he would say
something and i would make fun of it and
he was like why is the why is the host
making fun of the judge
keenan uh keenan ivy wayans roseanne we
all like they were all like why is he
being mean to us and that was just the
way i did things right but i was uh
thrilled to be able to work with norman
mcdonald and get to know him a little
bit uh huge huge influence on me of just
if you believe in the joke the audience
doesn't have to necessarily right
because you get it like his weekend
update was amazing legendary to me and
just one of the greatest of all time i
i'm i'm uh
you know i i don't these don't affect me
that often but this is uh this is a
tough this is a this is a what does it
say i didn't read it what did he die
from
somebody in the control what did he pass
from it was cancer
he has he been sick cancer
nine years
he's had nine years of cancer i had no
idea i had no idea
that he was even sick
um
he's a guy that i knew a little bit i
was definitely friendly with them we saw
each other we said hello and we shot the
[ __ ] but it wasn't like someone that i
talked to on the phone or anything
and i was such a huge fan of his and i
would just always end up running into
him
and he just always had that smile on his
face
like as you talked to him he would have
that smell just just a really great warm
guy my girlfriend called me crying two
days ago what were you crying norm
norman oh i was like norm i was watching
i
i tossed on his uh his last letterman
she heard she was in the other room just
heard me like
like doing that and she came out i was
like
fine yeah fine yeah norms norm got me
that was i really that guy oh
he reached out when i was getting
canceled a lot really yeah and he said
some really cool things i'll share them
with you
so there's he's the best all right he i
reached out to i
posted about him when he got in trouble
yeah and he reached out to me and was
and was like
what do you i'll share with you
privately he loved comedy and he loved
the purest he was the purest comic and
he [ __ ] hated this [ __ ] workshop
yeah he hated it so it's seeing all
these people like tweet about him like
oh i loved norm and all this like just
know he [ __ ]
despised what you do
in my opinion
can you share some of the stuff uh with
norm yeah yeah that you have a norm i
was just
he reached out he was a big uh
when people were going through it norm
was one of the guys that would always
reach out and uh yeah that was it just
reached out he sent me some cool stuff
about like
funny will win yeah that was the coolest
[ __ ] ever yeah yeah it was like there's
a war right there i don't want to
i don't want to spill the beans on a
nice thing but it was like you guys had
a private thing yeah it was cool and it
ended up supportive yeah he spoke like
poetically yeah it was awesome yeah and
it ended one of the messages ended with
like in a war for comedy i think the
ones with jokes will win uh just like yo
yeah that's fire nor macdonald is king
yeah yeah and he in no way has to do
that no you know what i mean to reach
out you know especially at that time i
thought was really cool it was two years
ago i mean
yeah as he's battling something no
disrespect way worse yeah yeah yeah
i mean he's like hey you need help i was
with adam eget most of the time in
austin the guy you know adam yeah yeah
from uh from the store right yes so me
and adam went to the cowboys eagles game
and we were hanging out and the whole
the whole time because he that was he
was best friends with norm yeah so he
was like going through it but he went
through it the same way as like
he we just talked like norm the whole
time like the whole game was like ah you
must have
yeah you got hip pretty hard you know
what's worse than getting hit like that
blood cancer
yeah it's no good that blood can't be
just like that the whole time it was
great i hope that wasn't sharing too
much for adam no but yeah it was fun
norm's the best it occurred to me and i
was talking to my buddies on a text
chain the other day a bunch of comics
and i said
you know
this wasn't norm's time he didn't want
to live in a world of don olmeyers
everyone trying to cancel everybody
right you know
it was interesting that he's gone now
did you know he's sick i didn't know no
me either so i think i'm gonna get fired
because i saw lauren michael's face he
was pissed so you sitting there super
nervous at this point i swear in my life
in my kid's lives i thought i was gonna
get fired
because i just basically said i don't
watch santa alive yeah and i never did
and
yeah which is not not a good answer the
message in front of the press yeah
and i didn't say it in a mean manner but
i could just tell the boss man was like
uh so oh jesus lord so now i'm sitting
there thinking i'm going to get fired
swear to god and i'm just like oh my god
even get i don't even make it the first
episode i'm going to let me go this is
what's going on my head
there has there has to be a video this
press conference in the black market
somewhere
i i've looked for it never found it
it's the 1995 press conference
and so
they ask norm they go norm
you tim meadows david spade
you've been here you you know the frat
house everyone knows snl is a frat house
what kind of what kind of practical
jokes you got lined up for these new
cast members
and
i swear to you i went
i'm not even going to be part of the
the frat house or the practical jokes
and norm goes
he first always annoyed he goes
practical jokes
is that what you asked what kind of
practical jokes
uh first you were thinking about anal
rape
you know
like
hey hey
hey take your pen we're going to haley
rape you welcome to sounding line we're
going
oh [ __ ]
he's going to get fired too
you can't say you know rape you from the
press
he said anal rape so suddenly you're
like i'm back in there i'm in it i'm
good i'm good
and i went up to him after i went nor
he's like dana again you know he has a
ship right
in fact
you know he's [ __ ] these guys
and i realized he would pitch
at the pitch meeting he just didn't care
he didn't care
and i learned so much from him
just
clearly he saw a lot and he's been there
forever like he would i remember he got
he gathered the new cast up he's a geek
i swear to god he is
yeah
don't write me any of your gay sketches
[Laughter]
he had a bit
he
he always had so many gay jokes but i
never knew him to be gay or anything but
he had a joke he was on letterman
and uh or no it was conan and he goes
he is promoting his book and he goes
yeah it's not a memoir but uh
and it's just uh it's a book and he goes
uh
you know it's i don't talk about being
deeply a deeply closeted gay man and
conan goes
what you're gay and he goes what
now why'd you say that because we just
said he goes now i'm i'm deeply closeted
and he goes so you're not good he's like
no no i'm straight as an arrow
he goes and then he goes and i'm
paraphrasing forgive me but he goes you
know deeply closeted means the guy is
gay but he's so gay you won't admit it
he hides it
and uh he's like yeah no i'm straight
it was such a [ __ ] good bit again i
[ __ ]
uh paraphrased it but it's on youtube
that's funny man yeah he was great
yeah i watched one of his clips and he
was on i think the view did you see that
clip
no when they're trying to get him to
like he's trying to be very realistic
the show's like ultra liberal and he's
just trying to be just a realist like
yeah that's how he was yeah and they're
like they won't they're like you'll
never be back on this show they're all
joking about it and stuff anyway he
wouldn't because he wasn't like just
kind of conforming to whatever like
i don't know just some ridiculous story
why would they have him on here we go
let's get a little bit of it that uh uh
the democrats don't steal the election
from the uh the winner you know but who
knows
[Applause]
you like george bush i love george bush
man he's a good man decent you know none
of this
and he's uh you know he's not a
a lie or a crook murderer or anything
like that so it'd be good to get the see
i i don't i think we should get the
homicide out of the white house and get
like a a a fresh start because we don't
want any more murderers i think we
should just go on to the next question
oh clinton he murdered a guy yeah you
know
you're not awesome but i have no
accusations with that that's a little
confusing
yeah this is not my week what can i tell
you
oh it's not mine either and i'm being
very nice okay
i'll be a good boy
now norm do you never hear that no
listen we don't need no one to get into
this and i don't want to hear it and
this is not the place to make those
accusations and you're supposed to be
funny
there you go
this is a live show
but you have been properly chastised by
barbara so i'm not going to ask the next
i thought it was a matter of record
okay let me do this okay
they don't even want to talk about the
fact that maybe the guy murdered
somebody
let's call football all right
manslaughter
he's doubling down so did you were you
open for him
no well i'm trying to go i hung out with
him a couple times um
the irvine
one was that was that was the time i got
really high with him
uh ryan sickler and i were in the
parking lot before i'm jealous oh and
ryan's always got good weed yeah he had
some crazy sticky [ __ ] and
and he was like
uh you wanna he's like you wanna smoke i
didn't i thought norm was gonna be like
i'm about to go on stage which he was
and he was like yeah i was like you're
gonna smoke right i was like you're
gonna smoke right now because that was
like so scary to me to get that high
right before
he packed his bowl norm hit it took a
monster
i watched him take a monster off of
cough rogan one time so hard tear came
down his face you know when you're
coughing that hard and i was like this
is gonna be
bad you know
i took a hit because i was watching him
we weren't we weren't performing that
night and um
the show's already started and i had
that like you know that anxiety yeah
like of like a five-year comic and he's
a 30-year guy at the time yeah like
don't you gotta get in there he's like
huh
i guess all i can think about is like
you got to get in there man
and he's he smoking talking told me i
asked questions i asked about dirty work
you know and working i go that scene
with rickles
and uh and and artie you know and then i
think i thought i'd tell you this we
walk from the parking lot into this is
the old irvine yeah yeah we walk in the
front and then there's the showroom
doors and then there's the pathway down
dude it's like a movie we walk in the
front doors and then those those
showroom doors open
and as the showroom does open they're
like norma mcdonald
he's got on this leather
uh blazer on and he's holding a coke
twist off coke yeah
and he just walks up there and and
you know place goes it was packed
and he's like yeah you know some people
drink sprite it's [ __ ] gross and he
just [ __ ]
it's like talking like that like just
off the top of his head about how gross
sprite is
and
murdering and then ryan and i are in the
back we're like holy [ __ ]
we're like he's we're so high he's got
he's so high right now
so high and he's up there just just
killing man but what's interesting was
that my comedy central roast that john
stamos was the roast master and all of
the comedians and that's where
uh beloved nor macdonald did his very
memorable
non-roasty
tribute uh of doing no he was reading
joke from a joke but he said saggit i'm
gonna do jokes from the 40s and i went i
don't know
i said say [ __ ] once i don't want to do
that i don't want to make funny you're
my friend
and i went um
i had a hard time uh i've had a hard
time dealing with this one i know and
can i just say not to not to bring this
down but you know i
i i was sitting here in the podcast on
the on the day with jeselnik and
when we found out and it just broke my
heart and i think it was like two days
later
um
i don't know if it was instagram or
whatever you did that was mine
yeah
and and it was the most touching
wonderful
emotional
um beautiful
i mean
is as much as it was beautiful for norm
it kind of
you're a really good guy and a good
friend to have in life and the fact that
you respect but you texted me that and
uh
i was crying i was crying listening to
you
i was that bad
no it was right as that set the stage
it's right as his netflix show is about
to air and he gets in big trouble
because he's on stern no no no hold on
start it over he he defends louie first
okay
and then and then and loads roseanne
then he goes on stern and when he's
stern and when he's on stern instead of
saying like like you'd have to be
[ __ ]
to like
to laugh at this or to think this he'd
be like you'd have to have down syndrome
so he keeps saying he thinks that's
better because he thinks down syndrome
is okay to say but regarded as bad
because it's the right word right right
so he's like
so he says in a bunch
and they're about to launch the show so
of course like you know everybody
involved is like panicking like you need
to make it clear you have a new show
launching you got it you got it so he
goes on the view and he's like yeah
he's like
yeah
he's like
and he is i'm like you can see you can
mute this and watch this he is eating
mints
like as he and popping them in his mouth
eating joe he's literally eating milk
and shaking it's like shaking him in his
hand he's like yeah i feel real bad
about that
and he's like
all right why did i talk about a little
bit i've never even had consensual sex
with a girl and they're like norm you've
never had consensual sex with a girl he
goes why would i and they're like no i
think you're misspeaking norm oh and
then you see like you see him like he's
on you're on daytime he's like he's like
he's like yeah so uh
i feel real bad about that norm makes me
laugh
dude
hold on i'll do that thing about norm
so he did this thing one time
he gets up and go from one room into
another room right he stops at the
doorway and he's like
what
what is like a
what is this he's like banging on the
door like just the doorway he's like
what is like a
portal to like another
what is this and his ass he's literally
asking the people in the room right
what do you call this thing it's like a
like a portal to what it what how do you
just go through where am i
and he was just talking about a doorway
but it was so he makes anything funny
yeah i remember it was me him he came
it was i think he was
doing a show with spade in irvine
and uh i went to go watch
and he came at and we went
we went like by the dumpster afterwards
and it was me him
i wonder what you're talking about
outside yeah that little outside area
where you park yeah yes yeah and
i don't know if it was
there was one other person there i
remember was there
seriously
stopped because what
jesus christ
[ __ ] guy from headbangs you can't
[ __ ] stump again i
[ __ ] you dying he was so angry
didn't want to get high he was so pissed
he was genuinely pissed the [ __ ] is that
who's the [ __ ] brewery [ __ ] hey
jesus christ the [ __ ] his work are you
sure you again jesus christ what the
[ __ ] so many people like pretend
that they don't give a [ __ ]
you know
both in my business and in other
businesses you got to be i don't give a
[ __ ] hey you know me i don't give a [ __ ]
you know those people that advertise
like that guy clearly in the best way
didn't give a [ __ ] he really cared about
people and stuff but like
like he did what he wanted to do
and when he was on snl how big a gig
that was
because there was so few channels the
internet hadn't blown up yet and even
with basic cable and everything i mean
it was still if you were on saturday
night live
and you were doing weekend update it was
one of the most coveted gigs
a comedian could have and
no one's walking away from that job i
mean if some suit at nbc tells you
they don't like the jokes you're doing
and be funnier
you know you're shaking in your i would
i would be i'd be like oh [ __ ] you know
i'm going to lose this big gig i don't
want to get fired i don't want to piss
these people off or whatever
i guess he was doing all those oj jokes
and somebody i forget how the story went
there was somebody there that knew oj or
something and
was telling him telling norm to back off
and move on to something else
so what does norm do he just doubles
down and he just does even more
oj jokes
which is like
you know
the balls that that took to do that and
he ended up losing the gig he got fired
and he was and people loved him and he
was [ __ ] hilarious but he you know
he didn't back down to the to the to the
big [ __ ] guy over there and he ended
up losing the gig
so
you know as luck would have it
i think it was dirty work came out like
a year and a half later or so
so he has to promote it he's on the
press thing so lauren has him back and
has him host the show
i remember he went out there in his
opening joke
this opening joke he just comes out
and he was just like yeah yeah yeah
something something like this was yes
good to be back you know i actually got
fired from this show back
about a year and a half ago because they
said it wasn't funny and uh now here i
am
i'm hosting the show so that means one
of two things
either i got a lot funnier
but this show sucks
and they did that big [ __ ] eating grin
in his face and he started laughing
and then he proceeded to do a bunch of
oj jokes but he didn't take personal he
took issue with oj
he didn't take issue with being if you
tell him not to say something it's like
us
right now it's like
we're the
i guess he was the purest version
of don't say this
and then he would find the most
brilliant way to do it he was a
wordsmith also he loved wordplay and
there was there was a brilliance to him
that was really quite singular norm
really was brilliant i mean
not just his stand-up but i mean
an edgy underappreciated
weekend update oh the best the easily
the best weekend guy and he followed i
believe he followed kevin nealon mm-hmm
who i thought was great as well neelam
was great yeah a different type of
anchor yeah dennis miller was always
like lauded as the best one and i feel
like norm kind of took it over norm was
our guy it's almost like almost like
people like i'm a letterman guy and and
then we're like well we're conan guys
right
that's kind of what norm was but he
would come in and he would bomb a lot he
would have jokes that the audience would
be like oh he had this one great joke
he's like something something women are
bad drivers and they went oh and he went
well i want you to know a woman wrote
that joke and they went oh and he went
i'm kidding we don't hire women
that's a comic we love you uh
norm we love your comedy he was a good
human being he was
somebody that uh i think we're all going
to miss
100 i mean one of the greatest of all
time and he really is only like
solidifies his legacy i think that
people really will i thought he was
really treated unfairly at snl when he
was fired there was no reason to fire
him i mean i i think he pushed the
buttons that he knew that if he kept
doing this he was gonna get fired it was
all the oj jokes um but i think he went
out in his own terms and i think that's
kind of what made him a legend you know
the fact that he never had the huge hit
sitcom he didn't become seinfeld i think
added to his legend that i think he had
an amazing career and his comedy output
is uh is unparalleled that uh he'll
never be forgotten
[Music]
you